foreign
[Music]
take a close look at yourself and I
would want you to answer a few questions
for me okay
does your basic body design resemble
your parents body
do you have two eyes two hands and two
feet
well I'm sure you do being the child of
two human beings you're bound to be a
human
now what is the similarity called it is
called as the basic structure of the
human body
every offspring of a particular species
will resemble the parents in its basic
body structure
when I say basic body structure what do
I mean
the body design includes the Eyes Nose
hands and feet and other basic body
organs
let us understand this better with an
example
this is a baby of a particular species
can you help me find its parent
is this the mother and father of the
baby
no what about these are these the
parents not quite similar though how
about these yes the baby bird looks
exactly like these two individuals what
helped you identify the parents of this
offspring
this is a baby bird and it looks like
the mother and father bird just like the
parents it has two Wings similar eyes
the beak and even the body shape
these external characteristics enabled
us to identify the baby as The Offspring
of these two individuals it is just the
way nature Works a baby looks just like
its parents this is called as the basic
body design
however a closer look would make you
realize that the baby shares a few
distinct characteristics with that of
the mother while a few of the father
this usually happens in sexual
reproduction when there are two parents
involved in reproduction
in asexual reproduction The Offspring
looks exactly like the parrot a baby
Hydra looks exactly like the parent
Hydra
when do subtle changes take place in
asexual reproduction
that only happens when there are some
unforeseen genetic changes while the DNA
is being replicated
only slight glitches in the biochemical
process can lead to subtle changes in
the baby organism
in sexual reproduction however this is
not the case
let us look at a baby of two humans the
baby has got eyes like that of its
mother while the color of the hair is
that of its father
these are called as traits which are
passed from one generation to the next
so in reproduction the body design
Remains the Same but there may be
specific traits inherited by different
organisms from the parent
let us look at this idea of traits in a
little more detail
what are traits exactly
have you heard people say the child has
curly hair just like his mother or the
baby has blue eyes of the father well
these are called characteristics and
they differ from one human to another
that is why though we have the same body
design we all don't look the same
imagine the world to be full of humans
who looked alike we would never be able
to tell one from the other and I am sure
we would have a tough time finding our
own family members this transfer of the
basic body design and specific traits
that make us Unique Individuals is
called as heredity
now we know the basics of heredity but
this concept isn't as easy as it seems
we have so much to learn about it enough
further videos
[Music]